なんか大学でスーツ着てこいっていきなり言われて僕生つ持ってないので
そんな何か他に今日スーツいるんだったんですけど昨日採寸に行って1日スーツ作って
もらったんですよ
いきなりスーツとか言われても俺持ってないからさー青山
青木2つのは大きいですね
スーツの青木能生しおばさんには本当に迷惑を掛けました本当に忙しいのもありがとう
ございますプールで打ちね
スーツを手に入れたはずの社長でございますどーんと申し訳ない
以蔵シーンであ
自民ので今日は俺の夜バーを食うだけの動画です
醜い血の色手羽先かれちゃって作り写ってるこうですね
美しき月夜その後はこれをミコルミサない日をマナー醜く5で止まり行く楽器三味わぁ
でこのがバリバリ乳首出してるんでちょっと youtube 的に移せませんやても
人間
じゃないからいいのかな
あんたやっぱダメだやめておきますランチョンマットが減ってるう
ほんとだ
うわ安すげー
安っぽいいやーすげーはこれか
ちょっとこれからいいのかどうか+みたいですよじゃないのかなぁ
あんまり可愛いって書いてないよ色だけ見にくい家なのだ
これでは案内か泣けないですねではあ
作っていきますバスターよ入って指で作っていきましょう
鍵掛け長いかホストみたいな壮大な爆発的な動画をしたいんですけど
芸術はね時間がないんですよ的でね自炊何でそうしないんでね
まあで取りとかで作るだけでももう俺にとっちゃ大きなしっぽなんでては2つ使って
作ろうと思います
第でいいんじゃない
ok 3分くらい待とうと思います
お前の血は何色だ
善悪ないんだけど
ああああああ
こんなもんしょんはいうわーっ
じゃあ次のさらにだしたカレーをねしますこのポイントでいいんだよ
粉もん
前に皿をミスったわね
とらん
いただきます
a
お皿でこんなに変わるもんだねそんなに悪くなかった水路は
いただきます
うんまぁどこにでもあるカレーの味です何か名前を聞いたときどんな味がするかと思っ
たんですけど
いたって美味しいですえっ
アジアンずポイント100ゴッドほかあれ忠保が電気からたえっ食いながらで申し訳
ないけどさ
実は俺も将来迷ってるのよなんかごスーツを着るとねちょっと思うんですよ
これこの先どうなるんだろうなってやっぱ大学を卒業した先がねぇちょっとまた自分で
もなんともわかんないんですよね悩んでるわけじゃないですよ
悩んでるわけじゃないんですけども春にはもう大学よね
先生になるわけでねその後は何かしら決めていかなきゃいけないんでね
自分の好きなことをすればいいと思ってるんですけどねなかなか将来が見えない初めて
ございますよお前らは分かっていると思うような
前世はいつとってでしかないからね俺にも言えることなんだけどさ
そこのマイロまーくないように行けなくあとさっきそんな is 音ズレのしたいこと
はしといた方がいいと思うよ
benq の中のご飯を食べながら言う奴に言われても説得力が無いと思うけど
お前ら明日が金曜日だ
雑誌ましたよいこうぜ上
me